I didn't hate it huh Justice League I
just got back and I don't want my two
hours back I'm I'm kind of stunned I
know I said back in I think it was have
you already maybe marched that I wasn't
gonna go see this but I turned around on
that since then because the reason I
initially said I wasn't gonna go see
Justice League was because I did not
want to financially support the vision
that Warner Brothers had for this DC EU
I just didn't think it was nothing I
wanted to see but I ultimately decided
to go and see this move because it was
very clear from newer marketing material
and everything that's been said about
the future plans for these movies that
they are not sticking to that vision
that I really did not like as
represented by Batman V Superman Suicide
Squad and to a certain extent Man of
Steel as well I will grant readily I
went in with very low expectations I I
did not think I was going to enjoy this
movie I didn't expect it to be as bad as
Batman and Superman be Superman now but
bad to my sensibilities before I get
into this any farther and let me say
this if you genuinely like Batman V
Superman first of all good on you I'm
glad you enjoyed that movie I did not
but if you did you're probably really
not gonna like this Justice League
because it is as I said a pretty clear
departure from that now it's not a clean
break from it it's it's kind of in a
weird middle ground like between where
they probably now have decided they want
to be in where they already were it's a
weird stepping stone but I'll get back
to all that so like I did I did have low
expectations going in I went in assuming
I'm probably not gonna like this but
I'll be really curious to sort of pick
it apart in autopsy yet basically and it
it was fine it's it's not great I'm not
sure I'd even necessarily say it's good
but it's enjoyable I didn't I didn't
hate any of the characters I didn't even
hate Aquaman I
was dead certain I was gonna hate
Aquaman hated him in the trailers but no
he works you know when Momoa is allowed
to do more than just go yell and stupid
moments like that which are still a
little stupid in the movie but when he
has allowed more than that he know he
works he's good in this part
Azra miller as the flash is enjoyable
and you know kind of you know ezel he's
a little bit he's basically he's not
ready for primetime to sort of where he
is but it's it's kind of it's nice to
have that element
you know gal gadot as as Diana as Wonder
Woman she's great she's been great in
that part that's nothing new
cyborg worked a lot better for me than I
thought he would as well he I just
expected him to be bland Ray Fischer
does a surprisingly good job conveying a
lot of inner turmoil with a surprisingly
little amount of actual screen time
devoted to that so I I was surprisingly
impressed with that um Ben Affleck is
Batman wasn't bad but here's a weird
thing he was better in Batman V Superman
but I'm gonna kind of come back to that
cuz I want to focus more on the
positives and then I'll get into just
sort of my issues because there are some
but the thing is there's nothing about
this that infuriated me or made me feel
ya offended which there were things in
Batman V Superman and Suicide Squad that
did both of those things and that didn't
happen here really then at any point so
you know that alone is a step up but at
the same time it there's nothing in this
movie that's like uh-oh that's the
reason to see it like most of your
really great superhero movies you know
we bought if they're great they're
hopefully good throughout but they'll
also have that and this is the reason
you need to see it you know in Avengers
it's that massive blowout fight at the
end where everybody is coming together
undoable honestly really just that shot
that pans are
and they're all there's like that's the
moment where everything's building -
Wonder Woman I'm it's the no-man's land
see he was like that is the moment to
see in this movie I I couldn't actually
tell you what the moment like the moment
of this movie is so it's kind of in it's
in a weird middle place which makes it
actually difficult to talk about because
it's not so great that I like want to
praise it to high heaven but it's like
it's not awful it's fine so it is in
that weird middle ground where it's lows
are not horribly low but it's highs are
not very high either it's pretty it's
middling
they also made the rather interesting
choice to very clearly sort of be
mourning and talking about Superman as
people kind of wished they had portrayed
him in especially in Batman V Superman
and not how'd they actually did and all
not just him like the world like there's
all those talk of you know he was a
beacon of hope and now that he's gone
the worlds is in chaos like I remember
watching Batman V Superman world was in
chaos already like the entire premise of
that movies the world is in chaos
because he's there so in a lot of ways
this is kind of rewriting history
a little bit in terms of acting like
Batman V Superman was a bit of a
different movie it doesn't completely
contradict it although there's some
other things that just logistically
don't line up nitpickers are gonna have
a field day with this but you know it's
very obvious that they are trying to
change gears for the franchise as a
whole and this they had to with this
very significantly so I think I'll
probably start getting into my negatives
III think I could probably keep this
review spoiler free cuz I'm not sure
well two things I'm not sure that
there's anything that I really want to
dig into that will be considered much of
a spoiler and the other thing is if
you've seen all the trailers I'm not
sure there is anything to spoil there's
not really any big surprises any big
twists to this to this story to this
narrative at all and I don't necessarily
mean that as a knock it's not trying to
play anything like a twist and that's
you know
where things get get bad but it plays
out pretty much exactly as you would
expect it to so in terms of issues there
oddly enough they're largely visual so
the first is Steppenwolf who's the
villain well before I even get into the
visuals of him he is he's fine he's
functional he reminds me of kind of the
lower tier Marvel villains he reminds me
of Malekith from Thor the dark world or
he reminds me I think best of Ronan the
accuser from the first guardians of the
galaxy he he's fine and he's there but
he doesn't leave much of an impression
he's obviously just there to be big and
intimidating and he he does that well
enough but I gotta be honest then he
looks like crap I mean that basically
the effect looks like a cut scene from a
ps2 game like it's it it looks like
something from it looks like something
from 12 13 years ago and what's
infuriating about is there was no reason
to make him a 100% CGI character like
the only thing that required CGI
assistance about his look cuz he's got
completely human proportions and he's
got a very human face in the design they
went we could have been recreated
instead with prosthetics and it's just a
big helmet there's no reason that could
have been done practically the only
thing that they need CGI enhancement for
is the fact that he's supposed to be as
tall as he is but honestly the number of
shots that he's actually next to another
person who was actually there you know
didn't Batman whatever whatever are so
few and generally are action scenes they
could have gotten away with just having
a CGI stand-in for the fight scenes but
then for close-ups had a real actor in a
prosthetic cuz those close-ups huh he
does not look good but I sort of want to
address the look overall because you
look at the earlier trader trailers and
the later trailers it's very obvious
that largely what was done under Whedon
and whether or not you want to say this
was
is intend to do it or this was what the
studio said they wanted him to do when
they brought him in to finish Kazak
Schneider couldn't finish the film this
is very clearly been lightened not just
in terms of tone and characters but
literally lightened the the light is
brighter there are fewer shadows there's
less darkness in it and on there's a
problem with doing that and that is a
lot of the elements in this both special
effects and some of the practical
elements were very clearly designed with
the intention that they weren't going to
be brightly lit I think the best example
honestly is the Batsuit because and I
hope the Batsuit looked fine in Batman V
Superman but it was shot there the way
it was designed to be shot it was very
obvious that Zack Snyder with that movie
had a very specific very dark and
dampened color palette that he wanted to
use and the suit was designed with that
in mind now they basically have him in
the same suit again well they've got to
they've got they've got him in a
different suit for the climax but for
most of the movie he's in the suit that
he was in for the majority of Batman V
Superman and here it looks really bad
and it's not because the suit in and of
itself is a bad suit or a badly designed
suit but when it when it is in bright
light it looks terrible and it's very
obvious that it was designed to be
heavily shadowed to not be this clear
and when it is it just it it looks bad
it's not a good-looking suit for the way
that they've altered the color palette
to make the whole thing lighter so and
there's other things like that too in
terms of the visuals not quite working
where I think a big part of that is they
were originally designed and conceived
and initially worked on with the
intention that everything was gonna be
darker than it ended up being and once
it was lightened up the things that the
darkness and the shadows helped cover or
were designed to accentuate now don't
work and for the most part cyborg looked
fine
there were how
one or two shots where he really did
look like a floating head he kind of had
the the Green Lantern movie you know
Ryan Reynolds head kind of looked like
it was floating on that body at times he
has that it's only in one or two shots
to be fair but what happens it's really
obvious I think that's about it for the
main set I think the last stretch of
stuff I'm going to talk about if you
have been avoiding a lot of the
marketing might qualify spoilers so this
would be your time to duck out before I
get there
so that's your warning here we go okay
so Superman coming back was interesting
and I think it's very obvious that Henry
Cavill is now playing what what what
they're hoping audiences will embrace
more Superman and this kind of factors
into them sort of acting like Superman
was a different character in BBS then he
actually was so oh and then another
technical thing I think it's very
obvious what shots they I don't know if
you heard about this during the reshoots
he had a mustache because he was
shooting another movie that it needed a
mustache for and he couldn't shave it
off because he was still in the middle
of shooting that so they had to CGI off
his mustache and the shots were they had
to do that it's really obvious they had
to do that like you get he's got just
was very isolated uncanny valley right
on the right on the upper lip and he's
who so because there is that but
honestly I I I hope that we get a Man of
Steel to following this because I feel
like cavil is much better at portraying
this vision of Superman than he was at
the very you know angry eyes of anger
you know version of Superman that that
we got for I definitely for BBS again he
worked pretty well in Man of Steel but
BBS boy did not work at all but I seems
they seem to be moving him something
that works better for him
now I mentioned Ben Affleck before Ben
Affleck doesn't actually
doesn't work as well in this as he did
in Batman V Superman and I think the the
thing is is that he he was brought in
and I think he was really on board with
the BBS vision of Batman and he was he
was one of the highlights of that movie
he was good in that version of Batman
this lighter version of Batman he he's
not bad but he doesn't he he feels like
he's floundering a little bit he seems
much less sure of himself
as a performer in this role with the
character having been lightened up
versus what we saw last time and he
doesn't seem to be making that
transition to lighter material as well
as say Henry Cavill is or you know how
well the other characters who are
brought in I think I like this has
renewed an interest for me in the DC EU
I I am I'm kind of I'm now actually
genuinely interested to see this Aquaman
get his own movie I this flash I don't
know what they're gonna do with him if
they're still saying it's gonna be
flashpoint I'm not sure I want to see
that story done in in film but I would
like to see more of Ezra Miller as the
flash I already wanted to see more of
Wonder Woman I'm surprisingly I'd be
down for saying more cyborg he was great
fishers are really good presence a
surprisingly compelling one but I feel
like Ben Affleck he he he was one of the
few pieces of the machine that really
worked for Batman V Superman and now
that they've they've tinkered so much
the rest of it he now feels more out of
place and if he does end up leaving the
part before the Batman gets shot I don't
think it's gonna be the end of the world
I think it's he's just not fitting in
this revised vision of DC movies so I
think that's about it um like I don't
wanna I don't want to oversell it but as
someone who did not like Batman V
Superman who knew who was expecting to
hate this I'm not I don't want it to
feel like I was like I was
looking for reasons to hate it like I I
went in as open-minded as I could but I
did not expect to like this I'd watch it
again which is not something hi he III
have not watched Batman V Superman again
I have not watched Suicide Squad again I
haven't even watched Man of Steel again
I don't even think that one is all that
bad but I'd watch this again
I'm not gonna go out of my way to watch
it again I'm probably not gonna rush out
to the theater I wouldn't buy it but if
somebody who was like hey this is on
streaming I haven't seen it do you mind
watching again I go yeah sure that's
fine so I guess that's I you know that's
my equivalent of a of a it's fine rating
so there you go so that's why thoughts
on Justice League
way better than I thought it would be
but that does only mean it's just fine
so what are your thoughts on it if
you're this far into it I hope you've
seen it because I did get into what some
would consider to be spoilers so
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that's
available on Apple podcast and stitcher
radio I am also one half of the punch
like a girl podcast that is a
presentation of the fire and water
podcast network fire and water
podcast.com there's links down below for
all this stuff and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]